l'activisme était une grande partie de ma vie ces
quatre dernières années
et maintenant je pense que j'ai l'
opportunité de faire partie de l'histoire de
différentes manières
le président comprend
que c'est quelque chose qu'il
prend clairement pour s'assurer
non seulement que nous avons des gens intelligents et de
bonnes personnes ici, mais que son
administration représente
ce pays
[Musique] [
Musique]
c'est important je pense que cela envoie un
message positif
aux jeunes femmes  et les jeunes garçons
aussi c'est important de dire regardez nous
pouvons vous pouvez être ici vous pouvez être ici à
la maison blanche en tant que mère que vous connaissez en
tant qu'immigrant
car vous connaissez quelqu'un qui a tant de
diversité et tant d'expérience chacun
de  nous
[la musique]
c'est
mes parents sont venus ici sans rien, je
pense que c'est ce que veulent les États-Unis,
venir ici en tant qu'immigrant et
pouvoir atteindre le rêve américain,
c'est quelque chose qui fait vraiment partie
du  tissu si vous si vous voulez
[Musique]
je pensais que j'allais être médecin
les parents et les familles immigrés pensent
que c'est ce qui va vous faire réussir
alors c'est ce que je pensais que j'allais
être et puis j'ai réalisé que ce n'était pas le
chemin  pour moi,
quand je suis allé à l'université, c'est à ce moment-là que j'avais
des gens vraiment formidables
dont je pouvais apprendre
et ils ont dit hé si vous voulez faire une
différence, pourquoi ne vous lancez-vous pas dans la
politique de changement de politique et j'ai pensé que
c'était bon  quelque chose que je voulais
faire et aussi quand j'étais à l'université, c'était
la première fois que j'allais en Haïti
[Musique]
qui fonctionne très bien
pour une fine tranche
[Musique]
c'est vraiment
bien j'ai écrit le livre à une époque
où les choses étaient très  difficile pas seulement
ici aux États-Unis mais dans le monde entier
et c'était une époque où je pensais qu'il était
vraiment important pour moi d'être honnête et
je me suis juste dit pourquoi pas j'ai une plate-forme
pourquoi ne pas l'utiliser pour de bon
et pouvoir aider les gens  là
et j'ai pensé que c'était juste une
chose importante à faire pour utiliser ma voix de cette façon
[Musique]
vous